I wouldn't be surprised if house Bry is
doubled in the next five or six years
doubled I'm that I think that probably
will happen I mean look at the stock
market what's the stock market done
what's the gold price done gold price
has doubled nothing's changed with gold
you know gold gold is still gold the
same thing it's been for thousands of
years price gone up because rich people
got more money and everything else will
go with it I've been saying for a long
time house price will go up house price
will go up house prices will go up
whenever I say that you get people in
the comments Angry Young People no way
house price is going to go house price
is going to collapse there's no way it's
sustainable house price are going to
collapse and I don't need to ask I know
who these people are these are young
people without without homes and the
reason these people are saying it is
because they they're terrified of that
happening and and and they right to be
because it's awful going to be so
socially divisive because a lot of
homeowners will be happy and a lot of
non-home owners includes a lot of young
people that will mean for them not just
permanent Financial insecurity Financial
insecurity for their kids and for their
grandkids these will be if they kids
these will lose capitalism and they will
be dropped off the bottom forever these
will be the guys who have lost Monopoly
and have to sit on the side eating in
tacos and pizza for another six hours
while the who are winning
fight it out like that's that's the situ
and I know that's why that's why they're
so unhappy when I say how price is going
to go up but I don't say it because I
want them to go up I say it because it's
going to happen really I don't see
housing as an inflation hedge housing is
aing housing hedge like if you don't own
a house you're short one house like the
flat position in housing is not zero
it's one because where you going to live
yes